[Music]
in dari vandalism news submitted by mr.
high-five a disgusting trend of people
licking ice cream in grocery stores has
gone too far
I've been watching this stupid is crazy
I'm so glad because one of them is going
to Jay the lowest IQ [ __ ] I've ever seen
why do people do that well let's see
this [ __ ] for the people that has insane
- [ __ ] yep so they are calling her the
Bluebell liquor you came in strong
if cuz when I said lick her I'm like I
felt like alcohol liquor to me but like
liquor okay this one she's [ __ ]
disgust would you do that you're such a
oh my god what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you is that like somebody's dad that's
doing it I know this holds like 62
mm-hmm there's like other ones that are
like more bold
about it - that look like they're trying
to be viral and [ __ ] there's this guy
okay yeah this guy he was intentionally
doing it to go viral and that's why he
is he has come to jail yes wait he
bought it he bought it back but it still
doesn't matter because the whole point
or like his charge is the fact that he
did it for nor nor ID and it's also like
spreading something that could be very
dangerous for other people to copy yeah
so that's what that's what the chart I
hope he gets [ __ ] up in jail but he
goes in okay but what are you in here
for burglary or whatever it is oh I
screamed well you know I bought it yeah
they beat the [ __ ] I bought the same
time well what if they're offended like
how dare you lick ice cream and put it
back you can endanger somebody's life
yeah [ __ ] creepy just robbed me of
like normal people what if my daughter
if I can eat that [ __ ] and you got
herpes yeah probably gets [ __ ] up
yes his charges is unlawful posting of
criminal activity foreigner ID and
publicity and criminal mischief good so
that's
dude we should all have teachers in this
game who would I scream like what the
[ __ ] dude
yeah so the first girl though that's the
first story that went viral with this
whole ice cream licking thing they have
identified her because they were looking
for her for a while and then they
finally narrowed down which Walmart it
was and it turns out that she's a
juvenile which means she's under the age
of 17 so because of that they will not
be prosecuting her for the 20 years
behind bars
let's dope what they scared her ass yeah
well so she's still gonna have like
repercussions of it but it's gonna be
through the juvenile justice system
that's amazing yeah we should have a law
where if you do this you have to lick a
hot iron tongue for tongue you know you
know like you know all the other like
the other punishments it's like the
reason why they don't want to have like
the death penalty is because someone
might be framed or whatever I don't know
how you can ever be framed for little
ice cream if your tongue is out and the
lid is off when you're recording it yeah
you should just look that's what's funny
is a first Hill alleged demand you say
that he allegedly did this thank you you
know the first video though I think the
guy that was recording I think in both
videos the the people recording should
also be in trouble but then the first
video though she was more like pure
pressured into she was yeah well that
was actually her boyfriend who is an
adult so I don't know if he's gonna
sachit to worry so he's on my left ER
and a [ __ ] idiot that pushes people to
do stupid [ __ ] yeah lot of people online
I've seen comments of people saying so
what cuz he bought the tub back but dude
you have to they don't realize that the
cops and like the grocery store people
at the end they have to throw away all
those [ __ ] tubs because they don't
know which one it is
yeah not only that but that's definitely
like very true but it's also the
influence of you posting it up and now
other people want a copy because they're
[ __ ] morons like I remember the very
first licking incident thing that went
viral was Ariana Grande when she loved
your doughnut and since then there's
been all these [ __ ] licking incidents
and that's just like that's not safe oh
yeah it's right you guys remember that
whole thing I don't know if there's not
really I don't even know where
but they put like needles and
strawberries yeah yeah guys like it's
like what five bucks to like buy
something like that and then if you do
something that's like detrimental to
society not only like if you're not just
like wasting five bucks or like you know
chipping off five bucks you're and your
influence got a whole industry it's like
millions and millions of dollars to
recall like you're wasting ice cream but
don't lecture me cuz now I want to do it
the way you just put that now I want to
do it hey Steve
why don't you don't lecture me like that
you know what's so stupid to like now
these costs are gonna go up because now
they're gonna have to put all that
[ __ ] annoying like tape and seals and
I [ __ ] hate taking off cuz I'm like
why do we steal everything but it's
because of idiots like that exactly and
then that made me think - I'm like wait
Bluebell doesn't have that plastic seal
to like rip off the thing alright this
should happen I predicted Dale will know
I predict that all those ice creams will
do that [ __ ] I don't know many ice
creams that do have this he'll never
remember anyone well they they have this
seal around them around the side well
it's always like you know like when you
open up a tub of ice creamy it always
sticks to the thing and it's just that
like yeah oh yeah even like tires like
this anyway right you just pull it off
hey guys we're trying to be invited
environmentally friendly like come on
like you don't need to use more plastic
for this [ __ ] that's a good point
that's so Jesus she's so preachy I'm
gonna buy a whole roll plastic when I go
home and throw it away
a whole big [ __ ] thing of saran wrap
in a dumpster really work for nonprofit
lecturing me she's not talking to you
start feeling I feel very talked to
she's talking to her nine-year-old fans
but anyway these are the the photos that
were circulating when they were looking
for this girl and her boyfriend yeah
there's a lot of [ __ ] out there that
it was going viral
like and people were just not in a good
way Bible like the Internet's actually
dope cuz they're all like find this
[ __ ] Doc's them like call the cops
like it was dope yeah cuz no one no one
thinks this is cool yeah it's only like
a small number of people that are like
oh yeah this is [ __ ] risky let's do
it well are you a lot
to do so if you can't lick ice cream are
you allowed to slap a watermelon at the
supermarket of course you can yeah you
know but you're near the lower lip and
slap it Lola no I don't do like that
that's illegal
oz it oh do it creepy yeah that's all
you what about the ice cream just gotta
give it like a yeah what if there are
Lincoln adjust see if the ice comes
right if that's if they should ban the
watermelon slap in there don't don't
don't eat samples you know what you take
a cherry and you just make eye contact
if we look like a random stranger
and you gotta rub it - that's a viral
crave no you can't lick your fingers and
do it that's [ __ ] up telling me what
to do no we gotta tell the kids
silence has they gonna do a social
experiment video we're like you lock
eyes or something bigger and another
what the [ __ ] but they know we're just
taking the watermelon by the way
watermelons on sale right now cuz it's
season 3 bucks or five bucks per water
man thanks thank you get ready for it I
just they are brothers daddy's dollars
for a watermelon baby and I slapped that
[ __ ] - oh okay you know how to actually
look it doesn't matter if you slap that
[ __ ] you okay like what do you slap I
still do it I don't even know what I'm
listening what's the right way that's
like no reverb you have to impress me I
don't know like cuz I just hear them and
I'm like this one battle you know that's
like coconuts I shake coconuts but I
never buy them ever you say the furry
one I've never bought a coconut one time
in my whole life but I shake them and I
like to hear the water inside
yeah I think it's like one of those it's
a routine like you go to the market you
got a slap each watermelon and you're
this entire don't do that I'd never just
grab the first one just grab the first I
don't want to be pretentious like I know
what the [ __ ] I'm doing so I'm like
doesn't look rotten alright so this is
how you in the bottom all right have you
ever seen watermelons it looks like
there's scars right it looks like a
spider yeah that's how that's how you
know it's more because that is actually
the sugar and content you know so you
want you want thinner white lines like
wider lines on it I don't know about the
stretch marks or the lines or anything
but you're gonna see things that look
like scabs
got it yeah you want the little [ __ ]
Scarface
have I been eating [ __ ] watered on then
when people see it because it looks like
it's it's like damage I don't want to
get that [ __ ] that's very poetic but
what it looks like your people you know
what it is is it take the ugly it's high
sugar content oh yeah sweeter right yeah
some truth to that I like that yeah good
job okay cuz I read it too cuz I was
like how do you pick a good watermelon
and they're like contrary to belief that
being doesn't work no one knows like
theirs and people just do it I don't
even know how to pick a good anything
even just like even people like peaches
I'm just like mm-hmm
you know we'll do that said let him buy
produce he brought an entire [ __ ]
rotten cabbage oh no don't you look at
what the [ __ ] he just picked like it was
all brown and rotten on the back of it
Nicky sent me to the store to buy her
sandwich bags okay my heart broke the
other day cuz I saw her packing a
sandwich into a ziplock bag those is
bigger than her body
[Music]
on the back
oh my god it's me I'm the problem she's
like and then she's like and I also said
the other time and you bought so much
bags that fold over so they don't
ziplock at the top cuz she sent you
twice you look it's my fault it's my
fault your fault
cuz I didn't get it either time I got
the deal both time well the first one is
actually a sandwich bag that's a that's
a little sandwich bag the one that
doesn't zip did she have a warning on
the box that says she should have a
person standing that's taken measures
because paper size we do when you see
warnings on boxes they're for idiots
like me who don't [ __ ] know and they
just read the deal it's like don't
consume this shampoo exactly
[Music]
[Music]